Yeah, it's a very touching moment to be
here. Yeah, of course. I would be uh
curious to uh to have a closer look now.
But it is of course very very important
that if you come here as a non-Muslim
uh to uh be respectful. There was a guy
who called cuz you know I do
fundraising. Yeah. For prayer project.
He's a non-Muslim. He chooses into our
stream and goes, "Can I as a non-Muslim
donate?" Of course you can. He donates,
calls in, accepts Islam. Yeah. And he
said the same. He goes, I was in Dubai.
I heard the adan and I was like, yo,
that sounds holy. Where do you think
that's coming from?
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from to Isa. If
you want to support someone like me in
learning salah, then sponsor 10 people
for just £100. this Ramadan. Remember
the prophet peace be upon him said,
"Charity does not decrease wealth."
Click the button and donate
now. And this section of the video to be
very different. I was planning on
showing you the area more. Maybe getting
some food here. There's also a big
underground market here. I wanted to
show you that, but to be completely
honest, I feel like this is an area
where you shouldn't really vlog much.
I'm like debating with myself. Like the
one side in me is thinking, "Oh, film
it. It would be so interesting to see
for many people around the world." I'm
thinking about the millions and millions
of Muslims around the world that don't
have the chance to see this place. And
for them, seeing videos from this area
would probably be really, really nice to
see. But then the other side in me is
thinking, "Oh, this is such a holy and
sacred place. I shouldn't walk around
here pointing my camera to everything
and vlog it." So yeah, for the past half
an hour, I was walking around here
without the camera, debating with myself
whether to uh to film the area more or
not. And yeah, I came to the conclusion
that I'm not going to film this area
more. And I know that the video would be
a much better video if I would film this
area in more depth, but yet to be
honest, this video I don't care about
how many views I'm getting. That's a
similar reaction I had the first time I
came here. Really? You know what I find
interesting? Okay, cuz a lot of people
say Islam is the religion of the devil
and antichrist and but I'm just really
asking this question. How is it that you
get people from different walks of life?
Like I done a reaction video to a a
young Jewish boy and they're sitting
somewhere where they can hear the adan
and the mother goes to him and she goes
that's the sound of Hashem. So in their
in in their belief it's God. I'm like
how could I mean you could just come and
say oh I'm scared of that sound or
that's a weird sound. Why is it? because
we're talking about kids are pure. Now,
this guy, he's a non-Muslim. We just
come to Medina and I believe that's one
of the pros of maybe opening it. I'm not
I'm just not saying I'm for against, but
I'm saying the fact that how is it that
people are coming and saying there's
something holy about this? Where did
that come from, bro? Did someone pay
this guy and say, "Listen, go to the
Medina. Here's some money. Pretend you
like him." How can it be that thousands
of people have the same reaction to the
adan? It's peaceful. There was a guy who
called cuz you know I do fundraising.
Yeah. For prayer project. He's a
non-Muslim. He chooses to stream and
goes, "Can I as a non-Muslim donate?"
Go, "Of course you can." He donates,
calls in, accepts Islam. Yeah. And he
said the same. He goes, "I was in Dubai.
I heard the adan and I was like, yo,
that sounds holy." Where do you think
that's coming from? I'll start with you
and then sneak on. Can I drop He said he
been watching Warner's videos. Oh,
brother. Brother, this is Oh, remember
Ryan as well? Oh, you're talking about
Ryan. Ryan. Remember Ryan? Bro, bro,
this was crazy. So, you know that guy I
just told you about the Muslim? We went
and met him and gave my guy the prayer
mat in person. We traveled. We sit down.
He goes, "Yeah, I binge watched I am
Warner's videos." Yeah. Guess who calls?
Bro, I bro I looked and I got a miss
call cuz me and you like like don't
speak that much, bro. This guy gives me
a mis call. I was right. I was like,
"Yo, I got ran. You know who just
called?" He goes, he go, "Is it?" I was
like, "Nah, bro. I am bro." You call me.
Yeah. Anyway, so yeah. No. So, what I'm
saying is that subhan Allah. Um, where
do you think this comes from? Because
you can't just make this stuff up. How
is that human beings when they come to
me or hear the adan, they're like, "Yo,
there's some something holy about that."
You know, honestly, just watching uh the
video right now as he was tearing up
wall, it almost made me tear up. Like
you could see the fra and locking in
him. And me personally, as a person that
gives dawa to non-Muslims, the look that
I saw in his eye, I've seen that look
for thousands of people. And that look
is I finally discovered the truth. Now
the test is upon him. Now that he
discovered the truth, are you gonna
allow the distractions after you go back
to Germany to allow you to forget that
moment or are you gonna now embrace what
the truth is and everything that comes
with it? You know, to be honest, it's a
very beautiful video. You know, the end
was a little bit waffly, but the
beginning, oh man, subhan Allah, it's
very heart touching. You could tell the
brother is being very, very genuine and
you could even feel the emotions through
the video. And yeah, may Allah guide the
brother, man. May Allah guide. I believe
he's going to watch this video, by the
way. We'll send him. There's a great
point. I have the mic. Um, when I first
read the Malcolm X autobiography, you
could the words that he wrote about
Meccco was what you could see in that
guy's face and the same feeling. I bet
you saw it on my face when on my first
trip to Becca Medina, I I didn't really
say a word for a week when I was here. I
was just quiet and just taking it all
in. I didn't take out my camera at all.
I was just kind of shocked and just
getting the prayers right. But if you
read the Malcolm X autobiography and how
Mecca changed him, he had that same
reaction where the hatred that he had
and being around other Muslims, the the
racism that he had adapted, all that
kind of went away. And he realized that
the the natural fisher that we all have,
it comes out in these cities for sure.
And hopefully this guy, you know, he
doesn't just abandon that feeling, you
know, that you're going to be able to
capitalize on that and and do something
about it. I think I think we can. And a
lot of people have this expectation as
well is that and we was talking about
this before as well that for you guys
live in America and in America the the
the Muslim the community is not as close
netit as we in the UK and the thing is
is that well because the land is so vast
so vast hard to be so which which means
your f your trials are greater and your
rewards are greater you know that's what
when he was talking he's like my um he
said he said um I don't know if he said
my companions or my compassion something
along those lines or my
And he was talking about a time will
come where there will be believers who
will believe in the prophet without
seeing him. And he said like, "Were you
talking about us?" He said, "No, I'm
talking about them who would believe in
me and they will not see me. You guys
are my companions." I don't know what
word he used for those people like maybe
us. But because it's the fitna is great.
Like we talked about like he's going to
have that iman hype. It's going to drop.
Do you get it? That's a part of test
because he's not going to have the same
reaction. But it's to understand that
people like him inshallah will like you
said capitalize in a sense be okay this
is a form of guidance you I'm trying to
say and guide yourself the the thing
that I wanted to say was doesn't this
prove to Islam being the truth because
how is it that bro you you haven't
experienced the adan you read the Quran
you even see like how Muslims move and
you're just like this is this this
cannot be from other than but God you
know for the for the Christians or other
people that come and say oh this is a
satanic religion I'm genuinely asking
what is satanic about it like how is it
that everyone has this unal
evidence to support that. They just
don't like that. They don't have the
truth. So, they just say things like,
"It's satanic." But if you ever ask
these people like, "Okay, how?" There's
no explanation. It's like, "There's
people worshiping God. What where is the
Satan coming? Read it. Tell me where in
the Quran there's anything satanic or
anything evil." They they don't provide
anything substantial. So, it's not it's
not even a real criticism. It's just
some people that are trolling online. I
don't I don't take that seriously. You
know, I found it really interesting at
the time when he was, you know, vlogging
or whatever. He felt like, hey, I should
probably put the camera down and I
should probably just, you know, like
embrace this moment for myself. You
know, that tells you something. Like, as
a person that first time he's been in
Islamic culture, he knows there's
something special here. My feeling when
I went to he can't even put his finger
on it. You know what I mean? I was going
to I was going to stream my Umra, my
first one, and I went to Mecca. I'm
like, "Oh, there's no there's no way.
Like, I I can't do it. There's just
there's no way that I wouldn't be able
to to press record." So, so if he's
watching this, which I'm sure this video
is going to reach him, inshallah, what
message would you give? What would you
tell him? Cuz you're in the da
alhamdulillah. Yeah. And I I I love your
da over mine all day every day because I
don't get into debate and this that. I
love the fact that you just stick to,
you know, it's not that I do debate that
I want to cuz I'm dealing with
crackheads and speakers, you know, it's
like a mental uh uh mental mental and
I'm the caretaker. I come and check on
my patients here and then. So, the thing
is some of them drive me a bit nuts. So,
you doing like alhamdulillah yourself da
which is pure just it's do you get what
I'm trying to say? What would you want
him to do next? So he's like I don't
even know if he's still still here. By
the way, I don't know if that video is
old or new. If he's here, we would like
to meet him. But what advice would you
give? What should he do next? So Sneo,
like you had that experience. Um uh
first you and then Sneo, tell us what's
the next steps he should take cuz he's
touched now. I personally believe he
needs to read the Quran. He needs to
open the words of Allah and then embrace
what Allah is saying to him, you know,
and then inshallah Allah will open his
heart and Allah will open his mind. And
you as a you you would relate to him.
Yeah. I I had the because I had the same
experience. I would say start going to
Juma every Friday. That's my advice for
for new Muslims and that was advice that
I was given when I first uh took my
shahada. They people told me some people
were saying like okay they're really
like embrace everything. I don't
recommend that as soon as he becomes
Muslim. I I would not advise trying to
pray five times a day immediately. I
don't I don't think he's going to be
able to. It's going to be so much work
to try to adjust his whole schedule. I
would say for the first like couple
months just at least do juma every
single Friday. That's already more than
most religions do. I grew up Catholic.
For the fact that meeting a Catholic who
goes to church every Sunday, that's a
really religious person, you know,
that's that's extreme going to mass, not
missing mass. So five times a day,
that's like a whole lifestyle change. So
if you could commit to that and then
being in the majid because that feeling
that he captured in Medina, he can find
a semblance of that in the majid. He'll
hear the adan, he'll be around Muslims,
he'll see the serenity. If you stick to
that for a while and then slowly
transition into, you know, more praying.
Yeah. Yeah, in the advice I would give
if you're still in Medina, get in
contact with us and we can give you a
guided prayer map because um obviously
it's daunting. I know how it was when I
was like when I went to accept this even
go to a mosque. I was scared. I could
there was a specific mos I to drive by
every d I was like should I go in shall
I not go in? It's daunting but I don't
know what it's about. Do you I don't
even know if I'm going to the wrong
place at temple. I did not know. So we
have a guided prayer m we can give it to
you for free in all for free anyways. Um
so that will help you to understand what
they do if you want to experience it.
Sometimes in our da table we give it to
non-Muslims and say listen some we do
yoga I'm like look why don't you try
this one they call out to God and just
use this you know it can be a method to
getting close to to Islam in
understanding if you're in Medina we can
hand deliver it to you cuz we're in
Medina as well in I would say read the
Quran like he said go to Jum like what
Sne said inshallah and the five daily
prayers each individual is different for
me I can remember when I first came to
Islam I used to pray them all together
at the end of the day that's what I used
to do I used to bang all them out and I
was like bro it's so hard how many is
that Bro, oh I think 27 if I'm not
mistaken.
48 uh
11. Yeah. Yeah. No, no, no. I was just
doing No, I didn't know, bro. Yeah, I
was not about that life yet. So, I would
pray all of them one time at it was it
was so it was so hard. Subhan Allah. I
can remember I used to miss I I used to
if there's one thing I can't do in this
religion is wake up a fud. I said that's
not happening. I cannot do that, bro.
Wake up. Now, bro, it I think I was so
traumatized by it cuz the second year of
Ramadan, I made du du du du du du du du
du du. I said, "Oh Allah, make it easy
for me." And I managed to do that. And
that's a reminder to us that anything
that you cannot do, I believe that when
someone comes to me and says, "Brother,
I can't stay away from girls." Oh, yeah.
You're right. I don't blame you. You
can't stay away from like what you're
saying is true. I can't wake up fudged.
I can't. I'm like, "Brother, everything
they're saying is right. You cannot do
it." Correct. Yes. But can Allah make
you do it? Yes, he can. Don't forget
that. You as a human being, you cannot,
brother. We cannot do. I cannot in my
ability wake up and I couldn't. Wah. The
second Ramadan I had, I remember I
sincerely made dua. said, "Oh Allah,
please make fud easy for me." Bro, I
swear to God, I can go to sleep now.
There's one hour for fud. I wake up.
It's not me. It's not Ali has special
abilities. Ali da Ali. It's not about
that. It's not cuz I'm holy, bro. Do you
get it? Like unholy shimole. Yeah. Okay.
It's not that. It's the fact that you
ask Allah and Allah makes it easy. Allah
says, "If you fear me, I will give you a
way out from places you can't imagine."
So I would say subh each individual
varies but we will give you a mat
inshallah you can use it and take it
gradually bro I always say this you're a
new Muslim do one pray a day one pray a
day bro sufficient work your way up
inshallah um any last words yeah you
know I wanted to say something my my
brother do not forget that moment when
you discovered Islam is the truth do not
forget that moment when you go back home
and you get distracted by whatever
distractions there are do not forget
this moment when your heart and your
soul found its true purpose you know
because our soul is yearning for the
truth and it's waiting for us to
discover it ourselves also another thing
I wanted to say as well for the people
who say Islam is satanic whatnot for me
what I believe is those who want the
truth will find the truth and those who
do not want the truth will discard the
truth so those of you who have discarded
the truth prepare for the punishment of
the hereafter it's waiting for you and
he is the winner I love I love what he
did there he just went in his zone yeah
do you guys watch that video of that you
watch that video of a guy who's um he
does shoe cleaning and he cleans the uh
sneak sneakers. Is that what he was call
it? And he goes, "When I've got the
foam, I'm in my zone." Haven't you seen
it? I'll send you. It's hilarious, man.
Anyway, that's why I thought that, you
know, when he got the foam in his zone.
Anyways, brother and sisters, sneak
together. He's like, "I don't know what
Ali's talking about." No, Warner had a
great ending and then you brought the
sneakers. I was like, "Oh, it was a
perfect m." No, no, cuz he went in his
zone. That's why. But anyways, forgive
my uh humor. I'm trying my best to make
jokes, but it's not working here.
Anyways, you heard it from the brothers
and I am war. Alhamdulillah. A great
ending. Most likely I'll cut the envy
out not to destroy not to destroy the
message. He's like he was here. He just
the guy's watching. He's like, "Bro, you
probably stopped himself again."
[Laughter]
Inshallah.